a game like that with colleagues in the morning
blazing who always likes to offend me sometimes
we
actually always look at the area
the variant has been over quite often
so in a wide variety of
variations we had that already
seems to be convinced
yes there should have been a
mood in the variant actually right
this bishop is typically a bit
unusual there
but typically black has
enough activity here
very often you just get the four
pushed through here
so
you always have to make sure that you play actively
enough
jumper i didn't really appreciate the two
when i pull away spinner  c4
the company
has seen that and i would really
like to actually i would like to
move away
in this position
threatens to take it too
i have to move away the ladies
okay of course that's a bit stupid
i didn't want it to be that way
until now not really
bad  for black
but still you didn't want s  o
have
good so i take it
so could swap everything here
so to speak
that should be good refers so rook of
the individual ochtum the 80
the bishop is of course much stronger
than the knight only because
this whole
this whole exchange action a
bit so we  not not
wanted of course he only has
these weaknesses that's the only thing i
'll make an air hole also
makes a kind of air hole
so
i can now do the winding up
maybe he also has a weakness
that i thought it does but
has  I think it's calculated too less
but I can now
take it relatively comfortably so
I'm
maybe
a bit worse but of course he also has a
bit a bit weak king well
so it doesn't seem like there are any
serious problems here  should come
yes yes I understand it
brings him here what
that next to it g4
yes it's the position that's tricky naj  a of
course not a good king either there
are always
possibilities if he
tries to go
for it here then the way is of course stupid
good and I can take a chess here now
but then I have
here with perpetual check
which was only made possible by the approx. 5
yes I play this for a win here with
the one with the pawn
check
well that's dangerous the pawn might
have played stupid then but
dangerously
check
yes this little trick and I hope
I'm hoping
so now I have more good between pawns
so
I'll have a look  I spend a lot of time that's
why you're not here at all try
to do something.
Remise certainly
alright, with the guy's trauer trying
to play for time
that's just okay, marcher,
that's rare,
well, probably if I'm involved with the
others then  I have
over time
jaja funny party I
somehow binder 5 I have a
bissc  hen got into trouble
after that which was definitely a draw then won
back for him as i had
a pawn more in darman player no time at all